head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts from cnr.com
Colorado Republican party says they will
withdraw from primary and convert to
caucuses if Trump ruling stands quote a
majority of the Court holds that
President Trump is disqualified from
holding the office of president under
Section three of the 14th Amendment of
the United States Constitution the
ruling said because he is disqualified
it would be wrongful a wrongful act
under the election code for the Colorado
Secretary of State to list him as a
candidate on the presidential primary
ballot the lawsuit was filed by citizens
for responsibility and ethics in a
dc-based watchdog group this We Know M
ramaswami of course said that he would
with withdraw from the GOP Primary until
Trump is allowed to B on the ballot in
response to this the Colorado Republican
party says you won't have to because we
will withdraw from the primary as a
party and convert to a pure caucus
system if this is allowed to
stand it's getting pretty dang wild I
must say now as we mentioned uh uh in
the opening to the show that's great it
it still doesn't matter because
Colorado's Supreme Court says Trump
can't even run in the general so if this
is if if this comes to January 4th maybe
even sooner Trump is going to appeal to
the Supreme Court I think there's a very
very very strong reason why the Supreme
Court will say no many reasons in fact
those though many many argue that the
Supreme Court will
intervene it it it is yet to be seen I I
think it I feel like they probably will
I mean this is way too serious I I think
it would I not only do I think it they
will I think it would be 7 to1 or 8 to
zero because the judicial branch since
the beginning has been very reticent
about getting involved when it comes to
votes and things like this they really
like it to be and Jefferson was like
like thought that the Congress should be
able to supersede what the Supreme Court
has to say they really don't like it
when judges strike things off ballots
and things like that or get involved so
this is the other thing that's very
important from a legal perspective is
Trump hasn't been convicted of
insurrection he's not this is something
that he's been alleged to have done he
hasn't been demonstrated or and deranged
is that so funny when Trump calls him
instead of calling him D just calls him
deranged Jack Smith chose not to charge
him with Insurrection so for them to
unilaterally basically backo uh
Insurrection guilty uh conviction to
this is really a bridge too far and when
you start interfering with presidential
politics and you're like one state this
is something Supremes really don't like
doing because this is a big bridge to
cross right and the Minnesota Supreme
Court said no he didn't commit
Insurrection this has to be decided by
the party we we can't take him off the
ballot I is that what they said that was
Minnesota they said that was their
official they said I'll pull it right
now but I thought their ruling was we do
not have we cannot supersede the US
Constitution as terms in in terms of
eligibility for they said they can't
rule on something a major political
party can can decide and they noted that
he hadn't been convicted so the thing is
like there are already Supreme Court
cases that say this doesn't work we have
immediate precedent wasn't this 43 in
Colorado if I'm not mistaken it yeah
well that was my thought that it's
immediately going to the US Supreme
Court to nothing unanimous be like this
is stupid why should it because this why
should it go to because it's such a big
deal I understand it's a big deal but
like I do think the Supreme Court would
intervene because it's a big deal but
I'll give you I'll play Devil's Advocate
if Starbucks decides to hold an election
to determine the the chairman of the
board should the Supreme Court intervene
if Starbucks changes the rules as to how
the election is that's a private company
and this is a private organization the
RNC yeah but no it's not private because
when you have there's all sorts of
regulations and things about who can get
on the ballot who cannot like they've
been law for example like you know
California is like a jungle Primary in
the general there's all sorts of rules
and regulations by what parties because
there's many states for example where if
I want to make it that I'm the
Republican Party only to Republicans can
vote they still made laws that basically
if you're independent you can vote the
different states different different
laws then Fair Point perhaps the Supreme
Court does intervene for that reason
saying the state has no authority to
intervene in a private organizations
electoral either way either way yeah
Works Robert Barnes tweeted out which I
thought was kind of yeah this is
probably from 5:00 p.m. 458 it said the
easiest path for Scot is to take in the
Colorado Supreme Court Trump
disqualified case is to hold a court is
to hold a court has no constitutional
role in excluding a presidential
candidate from the ballot in the first
place that that is a choice the
Constitution gives to State Legislature
in Congress however this is a private
entity that is being affected by this
but but again it's it's fair to say this
is the state government intervening in a
private entity it I think there's a
strong argument considering what we saw
with Texas V Pennsylvania in 2020 that
is it 2020 to 2021 the Supreme Court
simply says the rules for private
organizations fall to the state to
decide the federal government has no
grounds to intervene in what a and how a
state decides uh uh nonprofit entities
operate or public good service entities
operate but my thoughts also go to
George Santos who God bless him have you
had him on by the way no oh you got to
get him on uh when there are a lot of
people in the house and I think they had
a fair point and I certainly don't have
a particular lot of love for congress
people when the Congress people are like
we can't kick him out if he hasn't been
convicted anything yet like this is
really crossing a line that do you
really want to go down this line where
like we are picking choosing who our
fellow members are cuz that ax is going
to be used against us at some point I
agree I agree but the question
is if a private entity within a state is
engaging in a practice the state says no
to can the feds intervene there are
certain circumstances abely I I agree
however I do think the Democrats are
going to start screaming nth and 10th
Amendment saying the federal government
has no right to tell a state they can't
run their own election as they see fit
there's no question that you're correct
because the Democrats will take any you
know opport like they'll be tomorrow
they pretend the tenament doesn't exist
you of course they'll use that but but
that's the argument they'll use and
listen they're also making the argument
that preventing you being able to vot
from Trump is saving democracy I I I
love it I sort of see this as an
inevitability and an inoculation like
the Supreme Court's going to make a
stand and say president you cannot do it
let's just set the president and move on
I I think it's an inevitability because
the regime isn't going down without a
fight and I've been saying this for a
long time everyone is aware of this
they're not just going to want dat be
like you know what we lost good game
guys they are going to let's all shake
hands go home their entire their ENT
right their entire two qu yeah their
entire ideology is you have to tweak the
rules until you get the outcome that you
want now in other cases that might be
actually a good thing if we're all
playing a game and somehow the game
always ends up with Ian winning even
though we're playing fairly maybe the
rules are kind of skewed for people with
hair length I don't know you know what
would be really funny what I think you I
think you're going to agree will you
play Trail Pursuit at the end no that's
just fun that would it is fun uh Donald
Trump appeals to the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court rules it was an
Insurrection and bars him from all
states there there's no way that would
happen I know but it'd be hilarious I
don't think it would be hilarious you
don't think so you get your National
divorce I I I want my national the
reason I use the term National divorce
not the other one is because the other
one don't say it I'm not saying it
because I genuinely believe it can be
done peacefully or very relatively
peacefully I am very concerned that even
January 6th a slight bit of violence or
9/11 you take which was a horrible
tragedy and then 20 years of war in two
countries had nothing to do with it so
when you have this this power
establishment in place any little bit of
violence is used as an excuse by them to
escalate things to the nth threshold
threshold and the average people are the
ones who pay the price and that's what
I'm very concerned about I think we were
turning point someone was it Charlie
Kirk or might have been Tucker Carl I
think it was tuck said that Winston
Churchill 1940 after World War II broke
out he just arrested all of the
opposition party with no charge they
Abraham Lincoln arrested chur didn't do
that he had a war cabinet say that again
Winston Churchill had a war cabinet with
the labor party he didn't arrest the
opposing cabinet uh then Tucker Carlson
was wrong he said that on stage that
that uh Winston Church went in and
arrested the opposition party just put
him all maybe he meant like some kind of
national front but not the not the labor
party in Maryland you had I think it was
like 29 uh Confederate sympathetic he
arrested the legislature yeah he just
went and arrested them all yeah Lincoln
they created a uh a corridor between
through through uh Marland to DC that
suspended all all uh
uh what's the right way to put this um
infringed upon your god-given rights
well wello the idea that you can't
secede except for West Virginia like
that doesn't make any you know what I
mean that whole thing yeah West Virginia
is very special we we're huge fans I'm
curious to see what will happen if the
Colorado GOP does say okay we're not
having a primary more anymore we're
moving to caucus if the RNC at the
national level will come after them for
that because again that's a that's a
move to keep Trump on the ballot which I
think the RNC doesn't ultimately want
either I think Rona McDaniel I think
the's completely right even if she even
if you think she's a great person I
don't know her at all the fact is where
the results like where where the omelets
You' broken all these eggs like and I
don't see any Backbone in her Ron
McDaniel's in the kitchen smashing eggs
with a hammer telling you she's going to
make an omelette but she's just smashing
eggs with a hammer what would that look
like a pressing her trying to cook
if the Republican National Convention
did a caucus what would that mean
exactly it's not the convention just the
Colorado State color like I I was the
first state they have a caucus basically
you get together and everyone gets up
and gives a speech about why my guy's
the best and I think you have a
headcount I think that's how Works yep
and so it's a bunch of people sitting in
a room and it's like RNC delegates and
things like that business owners people
people show up think a lot of regular
people show up and then if you're the
Democrats you take three days to figure
out what the votes are yeah but it's
because these are in in a technical
legal sense these are private
organizations that can run their systems
as they see fit so when they decide
super delegates and the Democrat side to
push out anybody they want to push out
it's because the game is rigged I also
want to make the point and I'm going to
make the prediction here and I don't
think it's G it's the kind of prediction
people are first like then they think
about like okay this is actually an easy
good prediction I think the Democrats
Plan B is not Gavin mum I think the
democrat's plan B is Hillary Clinton
with nuum as VP so I'm I'm staying it
right here if they pull Biden for some
reason or if he's incapacitated they're
going to run Hillary and they'd be smart
to do it $11,000 it will not be Hillary
Clinton uh that if if Biden's pulled I
I'm not making a real bad I'm kidding
I'm making a reference to I got I got
you I felt like they were kind of teeing
up Camala Harris might there's no way
they cut tee har I I I don't know why
they would pick her but because they're
sending her on this national
pro-abortion tour she's basically
already on the Campa because they don't
want her making trouble in Washington
they're like stay busy I'm serious did
you see the uh she's going on tour they
announced one date and they're like
we'll tell you the rest of the get the
get out of here the latest the latest
clip from her where she's like this is
the most election we've had in you know
our lifetimes and I'm just like can you
she meant most important I guess thing
is when your gaps are worse than Joe
Biden's it's really bad here's the other
thing can you imagine being a guy who
got put can I use the b word on the show
which one is that b t I don't know I
guess I you call someone demed we don't
care about demonetization the swearing
is usually because like people might be
in their living room with their kids
I'll just say I'll say B I'll say I got
I got it I got it can you imagine being
some guy who's in jail in California cuz
this witch put you in jail like you're
watching you're like how the hell did
she convince this jury yeah she's just
cackling at my crimes thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time